Disconnect is three different stories
that were pulled right out of the
headlines and dramatized and then
threaded together,
you know,
to,
to create an emotional thriller.
It's about the way that technology,
all these screens in our lives can,
uh,
can bring us closer and then can also,
keep us farther apart from,
from each other.
And,
uh,
the movies not just about technology,
it's also about the way in which we
communicate with each other about how
people talk to each other.
Um,
and uh,
that was very interesting to me and very
important to me to explores the way in
which we communicate and to me
ultimately the movies much more about
the power of human communication.
Um,
then about technology.
Technology is neither good nor bad.
It is a reflection of us,
you know,
technology puts,
puts,
makes bombs and it,
and it can,
you know,
put,
put us on Mars.
I've met people who were very
distractable people who are always on
their phones.
They were distractible people to begin
with.
And I've met wonderfully calm and wise
people who keep their phones in their
pockets.
And especially during dinner.
Those were calm and centered people.
So I don't think technology makes us do
anything.
I think it's a personalities that are
expressed through all these devices that
we have.
And that's one of the things,
the,
uh,
the film tries to explore.
We've never had been able to be as close
with all these people everywhere in our
lives on different continents before,
as we have now.
And that's very exciting.
Um,
but when you are connected to thousands
of people,
um,
it's,
it's hard to find time for the people
that you really want to connect with,
you know,
so that's just one of the ways in which
the duality of technology affects our
attention span.
I mean,
we've never been in the history of
mankind connected with so many people
that we've never been asked to focus on
so many different things until this time
right now.
Um,
now we are,
you know,
it is so easy to talk to a,
to 300 people in a day.
So it's an exciting time,
I think for us,
for us humans.
Um,
but with it comes a,
that was Samantha's phone that just went
off and gave us a little interlude.
It was.
But I think it's really exciting.
You know,
I love technology.
I'm excited that I was alive when the
Internet exploded.
This is not an anti technology movie at
all,
but it's asking questions that I think
everyone is asking every day,
how much time do you spend on the
internet or how much time do you spend
on your phone?
How much time do you spend connected
with those 100 people as opposed to
those 100 people,
you know,
who do you really give your time and
your attention to a,
these are decisions we have to make now
every day.
Whereas,
you know,
10,
20 years ago we didn't have to make
those decisions.
You know,
we just sort of hung out with whoever
was in front of us.